yes well first of all it's a very old
theory because no no no government in
any high civilization and in many low
civilizations no government will send
young men into battle to kill and be
killed without offering some
justification for what they are doing
and so just war theory is simply an
argument about what justifications make
sense what are the plausible
justifications and how do we as citizens
judge what governments do when they go
to war and the Greeks had arguments
about when to fight and how to fight and
there are biblical accounts of arguments
in the Islamic tradition there are
arguments and Just War theory as a as a
doctrine it comes out of Catholic moral
theology in the Middle Ages so it's a
this is an ongoing of a very long
ongoing argument and in and in among us
the argument has has a double character
there are arguments about when to go to
war when is it just to fight this is
called yad bellum the justice of war and
and we hang on issues of aggression it's
right to resist an attack just as you
could resist on the city street if you
were mugged you could fight back and
that would be a just miniature version
of a just war and it's also just to come
to the aid of the victim of aggression
as you might do on a city street if you
were brave enough and that would be a
just a--just war and we've also begun to
think that when there is a massacre
going on inside a state when a
government is massacring some minority
or maybe even not a minority a majority
of its citizens the way the Cambodian
Khmer Rouge regime
did that it is just to go in and stop it
by force if necessary so those are the
just occasions of war and then there is
justice in war you're in Bello Justice
in the conduct of war and that hangs
mostly on issues of noncombatant
immunity of discrimination of attacking
only other soldiers so it's it hangs on
a very old idea that war is a combat
between combatants from which
non-combatants should be shielded
non-combatants means women children old
men
it means medical personnel it means
religious officials that it so it has
even meant in some circumstances the
merchants who sell weapons to both sides
were in some accounts treated as
non-combatants whom nobody should attack
but basically for us it means the
civilian population is not should not be
subject to attacking war one challenge
which I've written about is to add to
you saw bellum the justice of war and
yoson Bello justice in war a u.s.
postbellum justice after war once you
have once you have defeated the other
side what are your obligations in this
what might be a devastated country it
might be a country if you've overthrown
a regime like the Nazi regime in Germany
and you've occupied the country what
constitutes just behavior then and
that's an issue obviously raised well we
thought it was raised in Iraq except we
never reached the postbellum we started
to talk as if we were asked as if it was
after the war but it wasn't and isn't so
in Iraq we're still confronted with in
Bello arguments about the conduct of of
war but that's that's an important
question and you can see it in the way
in something like the NATO Protectorate
in Kosovo we fought a mini war with
the Serbs and Kosovo was then put under
a kind of NATO Protectorate with UN
authorization and and then what should
NATO do we have soldiers in Kosovo what
should they be doing what constitutes
adjust just conduct when you're
occupying somebody else's country